this is football when fans feel betrayed
exploited and fearing for their club's
existence
West Bromwich Albion one of England's
first League clubs 135 years ago but now
with an owner who's burdened them with
loans
and fans feeling helpless the biggest
worry as me as a fan is
not selling the club not realizing the
club isn't worth what he paid for it or
what he thinks the club is worth
he doesn't sell and we end up in
administration and that is a reality
absolute reality
I chose him to say that but it is
and it's this anguish this helplessness
where the government is intervening just
like utilities and financial services
football is set to be the latest
industry with an independent regulator
imposed it's got to be a good thing for
fingers football but the regulator have
got to have teeth it's got to be able to
to make real change
changing who approves new owners
currently it's the role of the Premier
League and the English football league
but soon a football regulator could have
oversight of that vetting process to
avoid having owners who exploit clubs
and risk Financial ruin it's following
pressure from fans that the government's
stepping in and they want a bigger say
in the running of their clubs to protect
them
from decisions that led to this the
attempt by six teams to join a European
Super League without listening to
supporters this is really unprecedented
scenes No protests at Manchester United
and Beyond saw the Breakaway collapse
The Rage that's produced The Regulator
and what started out as a few is now in
number Rogue owners or owners who have
speculated as owners who perhaps egos
them away or or who just want to make a
financial turn we need to do everything
we can to sort of stop that stop stop
those abuses I think a regulator
independence strong property supported
by the legislation should be capable of
doing that
however much resistance there's been
from football and the Premier League in
particular it's Parliament not the pitch
where the future of the national sport
is being shaped Rob Harris Sky News
Westminster